just in case things go deep we got
donuts to bail us out I think they just
don't have an epileptic fit here you go
I'm kidding
should I take it now no no next week
yeah
okay
[__] thing
this show is brought to you by Blue
Apron
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free that's right
you get your first three meals for free
and there's free shipping
when you go to blueapron.com Joey you'll
love how good it feels and tastes to
create incredible home-cooked meals with
blue apron so don't wait that's
blueapron.com Joey
our show is also brought to you by
indochino
indochino is offering our listeners any
premium suit for just 3.99 that's up to
50 off
and to get that you go to indochino.com
and enter promo code church at checkout
and to make it even better they're
paying for shipping so go to
indochino.com and then enter promo code
church at checkout
show is also brought to you by onit.com
go to onnit.com and use code word church
to save 10 on all their amazing
optimization products like Alpha Brain
new mood immune new mushroom turkey
Community Support
it's Wednesday night [__] suckers
here we go
taking a little psychological ride which
and [__]
kick that meal away kick that meal they
want to hear this they want to hear this
oh [__]
what
the Church of What's Happening Now
[__]
coming at you direct
Lee Syed
Uncle Joey
here we go
black lives matter there you go listen
to this shitty right here here you go
[Music]
a white dude could never play that bass
that's all funk that's all so
how can you shoot that [__]
he had a weapon no he had a base
what's happening you bad [__]
Joey here with his main Goomba on his
28th [__] birthday thank you so much
my main man Lee syat what's going on how
was your birthday today my brother it
was good it was um when I first got here
it used to bum me out when I used to
work on my birthday
oh yeah I forget what comedian has a
joke about it I think it might be Jim
Gaffigan having to work on your birthday
sucks but it's just uh it's kind of
weird it kind of turns into like almost
any other day but it's always it's just
nice to get to talk to people that I
haven't got to talk to in a while who'd
you talk to I talked to uh Steve Simone
I talked to Johnny Rock I talked to my
parents a couple times had lunch with
Paula it was the
have a lonely [__] birthday
everyone's gonna have a lonely but she's
studying for the bar so there's a [__]
nobody has a lonely birthday what are
you [__] crazy I get uh
took a lot of [__] in my birthdays I
talk a lot of [__] about birthdays
because
you know I live in L.A we live in L.A
and people invite you to be seven
o'clock birthday parties in L.A and
they're a bunch of jerk offs they you
know they drive in traffic and there's
eight people nine people they half the
people that don't show up this guy shows
up with this guy and it's a [__] and
then the tab comes and everybody's
looking at each other with rabbit ears
and there you are [__] paying for
that you know it's a [__] nightmare I
hate those birthday parties they're too
[__] fake for me but
uh whenever somebody has a birthday
whenever somebody says it's their
birthday I think back to my [__] 23rd
birthday
you know that's what I always think back
then was it good or bad it was just it
wasn't that it was good or bad
it's that I spent it alone
but it was at a time when
I didn't need to spend it alone
like I just needed some communication
and I had a little communication in the
daytime but that was it I was on my own
the rest of the day
and I took care of myself I had like a
my favorite Chinese food and I had a
little bit of pot you know it wasn't a
bad day like I was under a [__] wall
or something right but I always
remembered how uh
it just made me weird that I was alone
and that's why tonight like when we're
coming back we were gonna ask you I
picked up mercy and like what do you
want to do and she goes I want to go
home I go to Lee's birthday what do you
want to do and she's like get cake get
cake you know so I go I was gonna go get
a cake anyway because
but you said you had to eat with Paula
so I wanted to take it to this new
Italian place we got turned on to that
even the baby instead it's [__]
delicious so uh we stopped it and got
you the cake and uh listen man it's not
like
it's a thousand dollar [__] car or
you know but you don't need like it's uh
if I'm being honest with you like like
last night because I thought I knew I
was gonna be alone today like I thought
it was going to be alone today and
you're right you don't need to be but I
always do that I always put stuff in my
head that like man I won't bother
anybody no no no no it's not that you
don't bomb anybody it's that
um
there's just this thing in life that's
a part of being decent you know where
you just tell somebody happy birthday
but if you know that circumstance or
whatever
and it's nice just to do something out
of the [__] ordinary you know with
people
I hate when people try to buy your
birthday you know like uh
give you like an expensive suit or
something I've always hated those
birthday presents I like when somebody
calls me and says let's go to movies I
know you want to go to that movie your
birthday is on Monday let's go see the
one o'clock you know there's nothing
going on on Monday you know what I'm
saying like that's the kind of [__] you
do on your birthday
after a certain age that in my mind
a nice [__] lunch
a nice [__] movie
you go home you take a nap right
and then you have family dinner with
your [__] family and they break your
balls and they go to bed that's your
birthday
that's as hard as I want my [__]
birthday you know people who really know
you yeah
I don't like the [__] shigma gigs and
people showing up and it's at a bar that
[__] drives me crazy at what point for
you did gifts become weird I'm at that
point now people ask me like my parents
keep asking me I'm like I don't really
need anything like I feel bad asking for
a gift from you guys
I always feel weird when I gotta get
from somebody
especially somebody from like the
podcast that listens to the podcast and
I know how you justify it I justify it
by knowing that we put out a free
podcast and entertains them at work for
an hour
and maybe if they didn't have a podcast
they would uh you know they didn't have
serious serious as 100 hours I don't
know a year or something like that so
people give you gifts and I don't mind
those they're very thoughtful when
you're on the road they're already
thoughtful and you bring them home and
you're like that was so nice to him
to bring [__] Pink Floyd or send it
to me in the mail or you know and those
are the type of gifts because like when
it's I mean everything that I've seen or
been given on the road is always
something usually something small
because it has to be they have to give
it to you but they know they know
exactly what you like well they listen
to the podcast yeah exactly it wasn't
for the [__] podcast which makes it
it's like you're gonna give me a wallet
you know who needs a [__] wallet I
love my old wallet you know what I'm
saying I stay with a wallet for I'm
broke let's throw it away once you're
broke and you've got a wall away it's a
kiss of death but if it's a good wallet
if you're okay with it you're making a
little money [__] you keep the wallet I
don't care how I don't care if the flaps
are falling off that [__] if
it's bringing your gears you hold on to
that while it really begins when it
starts yeah
you got to make adjustments you got to
put that picture grandma in the drawer
instead of Carrie who gives a [__] she's
dead you cash the check it's over
she's on some Planet whatever the [__]
who knows I don't know uh it's just
really weird that I just don't like uh
spending birthdays ever since that
birthday that birthday really solidified
of me like I said I don't want to go to
an amusement park I don't want to have
nothing I don't want a hundred happy
birthdays on [__] Facebook or Myspace
or whatever the [__] it is
I just want you to just treat me
normally
that's it
I don't want to go [__] him to a party I
don't want to make kazoo hats I do it at
the house now for Mercy we got a Carvel
cake tonight that we're not absolutely
yeah oh yeah it was nice and it was
delicious so the Diaz family tradition
is when there's a birthday you got a
small Carvel cake whether you want it or
not
whether you want it or not that's it
that's the best we could do for you it's
a small Carvel she was so excited I came
in she's like we have a surprise there's
cake and I was like and there's nothing
I knew it was going to be a carton okay
because it's you like you never there's
no there's no other cake for you there's
no vanilla cake do you ever have cake
like that are you just use your recover
oh man
listen there's two cakes I like there's
that [__] Carvel cake and that
chocolate that from that [__]
restaurant you go over in Burbank oh
yeah that's it I'm part of it after a
while I'll [__] take tastes the same
they enter all tastes like somebody made
it from [__] Betty Crocker that [__]
drives me crazy
if you're gonna make me a Betty Crocker
cake listen don't bring a Betty Crocker
cake to the [__] thing leave it next
to the ranch dressing because I'm
already Betty Crockett the [__] out how
many Betty Crocker cakes can you eat
your [__] life eight thousand yes
they're delicious when you're 22 and 16.
but when you're 40 and they show up with
that cream cheese [__] dressing I
want to stab me in the [__] neck be
original switch up on the [__]
frostings I know what that [__] [__]
looks like that that that uh whatever
that cup that comes that you lick the
sides when that thing dries a little bit
that's cancer
look at it when that chocolate dries on
a spoon that's canceled what do you
think I threw those CBD drops now
because I'm scared of all those [__]
spoons I licked with that [__] cancer
on it you normally containers of that
[__] I ate when I was a kid just getting
high you would eat containers of
frosting the frosting [__] that put me
in three other [__] Savages and ask
me
rather than Snowmass the guys from
Mankato upstairs would eat that [__] at
night when they got on what would you
dip it in dip like a spoon just spoon
this straight frosting three of us with
three [__] spoons bam bam bam bam bam
bam that chocolate frog fudge whatever
that's cancer you could taste the cancer
particles as you're eating it yeah it's
like all chemicals yeah delicious yeah
no no and you know what it's like it's
only it's like Hostess Cakes I grew up
on Hostess Cakes those [__] apple
pies delicious those uh the yo-yo
whenever the [__] they are the circle
thing with the whatever in the middle
made my hostess look like what a yum
yums
yodels those things I grew up on those
[__] things you look at a yodel
that's cancer those little cancer sticks
that's cancer but they're [__]
delicious while you're eating them you
know you like chemo can suck my dick you
don't give a [__] about that [__] it's
the truth go down and get one of those
apple pies now they're [__] they're
still delicious and you know you're
getting diabetes like as you're eating
it look at the calorie count on it it's
like H apple pie is 600 [__] calories
I never even tried those so are those
like just little handheld apple pies
yeah those Hostess pies that now
everybody makes like three the Isis
makes one [__] 7-Eleven took over the
company they make one and then uh
Hostess has made this this Jesus Lives
Chicago and also the 7-Eleven [__]
steals the idea how are the Isis ones
are the Isis ones good
they're not bad they're not bad I had
one one night in desperation somewhere
they're not bad I love those apple pies
dog I grew up on 38th Street once we
walked up to the [__] uh the dragon
the Chinese dragon that's the first
thing when you walked in there when you
walked into hashways that's the first
thing you saw a rack for [__] Hostess
Cakes
the donuts the chocolate donuts are
delicious they make a box of chocolate
donuts you ever take a box of Hostess
chocolate donut the little one the
donuts a box oh yeah oh my God I'm
probably eaten enough for a display
those things I like to I like the glazed
ones and you know what those are the
only time I get powdered Donuts those
little white ones I never buy powdered
Donuts yeah those little white ones are
good you know what they're good with
what what do I hate
milk oh but you know what those powdered
Donuts are good with milk you dip those
pot of donuts in a little bit of milk
let it drain really good so you can't
taste the milk [__] delicious [__]
delicious you understand me [__]
delicious
so how you feeling man how's the nose
feeling the nose is [__] tremendous I
gotta give kudos to Dr Mazza and Dr
Lion's Office Everything Is Beautiful
I'm sniffing I'm off the [__] Afrin
uh two weeks now 10 days whatever
um I'm breathing it's overwhelming at
first when you walk and when you go on
the elliptical
and when you do kettlebells I mean but I
have to reprogram my breathing so I had
to start reading Dr belisa's book from
scratch again and that's what I started
doing Saturday was just doing those
exercises that she teaches you know the
the the cat
the cat Cow position exhaling and
breathing sitting down and feeling your
[__] pelvis I've been doing that
again just to try to get I want the next
mission is to get the sleep apnea mask
off so we got to shrink the [__] neck
I'm not going under surgery that means
we're going into deep [__] murky
Waters of exercise I got a new plan
going on so if you lose it like wait
you'll be able to get rid of the battery
I hope so I hope so I burned a lot of
this fat around my [__] neck if you
look at pictures from The Longest Yard
in this [__] my neck is shrunk a lot you
know what I'm saying you can see my
Adam's Apple again there was a wall
there you can see it was just a [__]
string from here down now I've got the
fat hanging from the [__] meat that
was in there oh yeah I'm not gonna go
get that out I don't give a [__] dog no
no more surgeries no I would never do a
vanity surgery like that
have they asked you to have they been
like oh you can do this no nobody says
nothing to you I'm just saying that I
don't want to do plastic surgery or
nothing like that that's not my world
nothing you know knock on wood I've
never really had a [__] with that stuff
and I don't really want to do that stuff
I ain't gonna get no better looking at
this point what the [__] am you going to
do to me you're gonna tighten my skin
around my eyes what are you gonna do I
had a birthmark removed when I was
really young and it ended up [__] me
up because
I was on my leg and I had a lower Walker
because I'm a [__] so I like I had to
I always have the lower Locker
and I I bend down and all my stitches
popped so now like I don't have feeling
in like half of like my upper thigh
like you got to be careful with those
there's no reason to do those I gotta go
see Dr Amy because since the surgery I
got a pain in my left wrist
I got the original pain that I had in
there it was really weird maybe it was
the anesthesia you get a fax after a
surgery so when I woke up from the
surgery guys my my Tuesday and Wednesday
night I couldn't even [__] sleep from
the pain in my wrist
it would wake me up in the middle of
night if I had left my wrist twisted or
something so I would have to sleep on my
right side and the pillow there was too
high and it kept slanting my mask it was
two nights of [__] horror the wrist
pain was so [__] bad now I stretched
it I did the [__] exercises and now
the pain that same little pain has
shifted back to my left my right knee
so that means there's a pain there's an
energy that's trapped in there I gotta
go Dr Amy to stick some [__] needles
and I gotta tell you something Dr Amy
hasn't even called me to check in on me
one [__] time so I'm really surprised
that's crazy that's crazy yeah I thought
about tobacco I haven't spoken to Dr Amy
she wanted me to come down last Thursday
she goes I'll call you Wednesday night
and ask you see how you are I never
heard from Dr Miami again so it's kind
of [__] up I gotta call it a monster I
gotta wake her up out of the [__]
grave
but something weird happened today man
something weird happened and I don't
like
I had to talk to him but but in talking
to that friend of mine
um
I remembered something
you know I often think about my life and
I think about the gaps
that let me get involved in the things I
got involved in you know unless you're a
[__] [__] you have to look back at
your life
and go okay when was the first time I
did heroin or I did heroin in my mom's
basement when I was uh 16 at 3 30 in the
afternoon when she wasn't home because
She Was Out playing [__] cards and
your dad was working till nine o'clock
at night
so you always think about those holes in
your game as a young man so someday when
you become a parent
you know you don't have those holes in
your game I came from a home that
my mom respected me and I loved her and
she loved me
but you know uh you act up
you act up Lee and something has to be
done
my mom had a couple different
punishments you know she had uh
attacking me and smacking me and sending
me to my room punishment or the punish
you punished for a weak Punishment No
[__] TV that type of stuff which is
the standard I could look in the eye as
a man and say I was not abused as a
child uh beat up or anything everything
that came to me I got you follow me I'm
one of those guys I tell you the truth
about that type of stuff so
I understood that but a friend of mine
poses I'm a dear friend of mine who I
love daily posted something on Facebook
that was a weird question about his
child that his child wouldn't stop
hitting what do you recommend
I saw it late last night I read the post
of these [__] people
and some of it was [__] but
something was mad I don't believe in
hitting a Child Lee
I don't believe in attacking a child but
let me explain something to you
you always have to maintain with that
child that you're an authority figure
and that's very hard to do
you know what I'm saying I mean that's a
hard job because you love them so much
and you don't want to like you don't
want to yell at them or like what what's
the reason because you love them so much
one two it's like if you had a job in a
warehouse
if I was a boss in a warehouse and I had
an eight-man crew we loaded trucks that
night
I would treat you with respect
and give you a lot of love so if there
was a problem you come to me and we
could fix it but at the same time with
all that love and all that respect
I told you about my work ethics
we're only taking break times off we're
working straight listen you want to get
out of here early we'll work through
lunch and we'll get out of here early
done let's go we're all in business if
somebody can't come in one night to load
a truck
let us know it and we'll fix it for you
we'll cover for you while we prepared to
get you know what I'm saying where
people wouldn't quit people would want
to come into the job whether they were
getting ten dollars an hour or 22 an
hour
you ever you ever have a boss and a
situation where they're just scumbags
they all the time okay did you ever
figure out where they were [__]
coming from did you ever think to
yourself like where's this [__] [__]
coming from
yeah I mean I would really I would think
a lot about like I would get bummed out
why would this guy act this way over
this [__] because they had a sad life
or something like that it's the weirdest
[__] thing so I could never see
myself acting like that even towards a
child
listen I'm not going to tell you Mercy's
is the perfect child because she [__]
not
Mercy still has a lot of Buck Wild
little things I told my wife the other
day Mercy has a couple tendencies
that scared the [__] out of me but at
the same time I'm happy she has them oh
my God that's tough do you know what I'm
saying
because I see her tonight in front of
you she wouldn't stop so I said I'm
sorry
and you kept asking like why why would I
why what did I do and she was like No
just say it you follow me she has that
quality where she'll say I'm sorry to
you
she'll uh
I hear a lot of [__] no I'm not
and I gotta hear my wife getting rough
with her a little sometimes my wife will
say get up get up you know and stuff
like that but I'll go to check what's
going on and I get where Mercy's coming
from do I like that she's telling my
wife no I'm not not really but this is
gonna there's gonna be another situation
in her life
or something's gonna say something this
morning she's gonna say no I'm not I'm
not [__] doing that that's the
tendency that I like when she says it
the the situation that she sent it to
her mom since the age of three
and she said it to me a couple times now
looking and talk to her in Spanish and
then she puts her head there
and then I asked her to apologize she'll
give me like 10 minutes
sometimes you apologize sometimes I put
him in the time I I don't dream I hit
mercy and choking the butt
um
a lot of guys that listen to the podcast
Timmy you know listen to the podcast a
lot he knows that
we grew up in homes down when we get hit
of certain age as men
we got a little froggy with our dads
and our dads have to put us in our place
you know what I'm saying there's a if
you come from a particular household one
day your brother comes in he's like I'm
not doing that
and your dad's like what are you talking
about you're like I'm not doing that
next thing you know it's a [__]
wrestling match in your living room
you know and it gets ugly in some homes
but at that point that Dad has to crush
that whole thought
that he has he has to push that
situation to the Limit do you understand
me
I do but here's the thing though in
doing that like how do you make sure
that you don't
Crush out the thing that you want in
Mercy like that no why not like you have
to discipline her so she doesn't do it
to your wife and you but you don't want
to crush it out of her right no no I
just try to talk to him when she says no
I'm not that I try to talk to her about
it and I know that at this age now it's
bad
for her to talk to me as parents right
but
later on I'll remind her of that no I'm
not
okay that makes different situations
and she'll have it already inside of him
because she's been saying that for a
year now
so what I'm trying to explain to you
when you have a man in the house
like in this situation my friend
something happened at school I don't
really know the whole ups and downs to
say this
but he seemed a little concerned
and I said there's two times in life
where a man has to step up to his job
and it's right now with him and his
child
where
you have to scare him more than hit him
do you see him talking today absolutely
I'm still scared of my parents so I told
him that to sit him down tonight
explain to him you know I don't care if
he's five
that he can't do what he's doing anymore
and think the way he does anymore and he
can't raise his hands to his siblings
blah blah blah nobody else
and the next time he does
that there's going to be some problems
and at that point he comes home one day
three days later and this kid's in
trouble again you know he hasn't really
ever struck him or whatever and you
don't want to strike your child but
you also want to let him know who's
running the operation I told him grab
him by the back of the neck you throw
him up out of the chair
you drag him to the bathroom on the
floor and take an extra walk with him
dragging them ripping his shirt in the
meantime
you get to the bathroom you throw on the
cold water
you pick them up you rip his clothes off
and you put them in the cold water you
take them out and you whip them with a
belt you put them in the cold water and
you whip them you dry them off and you
make them go in his room naked and he's
in there for seven days
Papillon style only to come out and eat
not even to come out meat he eats his
meals in there and while he's in there
for entertainment he's got it right I
will not disobey why will not disrespect
well I will not raise my hand to such
and such to his [__] fingers bleed
if he's not in school that's what he's
doing
and it was so weird about me telling her
the story I remember where I got this
from
and let me tell you something
the person who did this
today in today's world
all three of those children are
successful
the two girls
married their High School sweethearts
they did not do drugs the boy did drugs
but today they're fine
they all got college degrees they all
paid back their loans
when I was a child my mom was a
godmother to a girl in Miami
are you with me and I'm returned
his father the girl's father Jacqueline
was my dad's best friend from Cuba like
they had grown up together okay so
for some reason he was away and he was
supposed to be my godfather but Gabby
stepped in and covered for me
this guy's name was Rodolfo okay and I
was very young I was very lucky at a
young age and I was telling my wife this
that I want this for my daughter
something happens to me
that I wanted to take cultural vacations
not to a different country or nothing
but different parts of the country
especially some part of the country that
is in her Roots like for me it was Miami
so my mom would send me by myself
to Miami from the age of six
to 13.
I would go to Miami every summer for
three weeks maybe four
and I would stay with this family and by
one condition that I did it accordingly
to their rules
so I had to behave myself
my mom would give me a couple hundred
and to give to them and they were
allotted to give it to me okay okay at
that age so my mom would give me 500 for
four weeks and I had to give it to them
and when I asked him for 20 bucks to buy
lunch from my cousins
they would say yes and they would give
me the money it was a really good score
now what do you look forward to it as a
kid or [__] yeah yeah [__] yeah
it was three weeks four weeks of being
on a on a beautiful property and going
to the beaches and going to baseball
camp and going to more beaches and going
to people swimming pools and cooking
outside and it was a Surreal Life he
loved me and I loved him the kids I
loved them and they loved me but the
point of this [__] story was
he was what he was
but in real life she was a professor in
Cuba
and she had been raised in a certain way
in Cuba she was a beautiful woman she's
still alive today
okay my uncle Rodolfo he's dead and
buried 10 times already this woman
did whatever they did but when they had
three kids and stopped
and became a mom in the meantime you
know a lot like my mom she took care of
herself and
she had hobbies and yeah from time to
time she would have a cocktail
but in the Summers part of our deal if I
went down there was that I had to do a
curriculum whatever Vivian said to me
like a schoolwork oh yeah so even if you
didn't have school it didn't mean you
were going to play all day
so let's say we would get up at six
and eat breakfast and stuff like that
and then we'd watch TV for an hour and
by eight we all had to go into the
kitchen
and she'd buy workshops work workbooks
for like you know this is crazy
she'd buy American workbooks and we'd
have to sit there and work on math
English reading geography
for how long until about 11 o'clock
for three hours
and then she would from there we'd go to
lunch or something
and then we come back home and do the
same for another hour but in that hour
instead of all of us doing it Jacqueline
would play the piano while we were doing
work
so the mother would sit with us help us
with our homework and at the same time
listen to Jacqueline play the [__]
piano and be like oh you messed up there
you messed up there do it again do it
again let's go and she'd sing it so
she'd be working with three [__] kids
and at the same time working with
Jacqueline on the piano
now they had a nephew you know the two
girls were great but the little boy was
a [__] up he was the middle and I
shouldn't say [__] up he was just a
little boy that was surrounded with
girls year round when you have two girls
and you grow up as a boy in the middle
you lose your [__] mind from time to
time they [__] with your [__] you know
and they get into a fist fight so he had
to rule in this house he couldn't hit
his sisters
but sometimes the sisters hit him but he
couldn't stay in so he would push him
and then he would get jacked up let me
tell you how they would [__] punish
this kid
no matter what happened where was what
time of the day it was let's say we were
outside climbing the tree
and the sister came out the younger
sister and she would say something to
him help me go up to the tree and he
would go all right and he would help her
up they'd get into an argument she throw
a twig at him and with his luck he would
throw a twig at her but it would hit her
in the eye and then she'd run and
bleeding dog they would just she would
come out the mother
and say oh fito come here I mean this
was Criminal
and when ophita would walk up she would
reach her hand behind this [__] neck
and basically pick him up like a clean
and then just turn around and he'd be
dragging he'd go I didn't hit her I
didn't hit her and I'm gonna walk over
there his shirt would be ripping this is
where I got this from his shirt would be
ripping and he'd be yelling and it would
be in a split [__] secondly like like
I didn't hit him like wait it was just
[__] crazy like me and you were just
playing you and I were just throwing
spitballs at each other and all of a
sudden the third spitball seemed to hit
you in the [__] eye I was right there
it wasn't on purpose but she didn't give
a [__] because she would say to him
before the whole game started listen
if something happens don't say no to me
later but that was his luck
that no matter when she said that like
if we were playing like one day we were
[__] hitting eggs or something like I
don't know what we're doing
he had that luck that everything would
just go wrong for him he was always a
year younger than me we communicate
today
and that's why I was thinking about this
she would rip him by the [__] neck
drag him to the shower put cold water on
and throw them in the shower with
clothes off
and sometimes while he was in the shower
she'd smack him with the belt depending
on the severity of what he had done or
sometimes she would rip his [__]
clothes off
dry them off and then put them in his
bedroom and you know what the punishment
was he had a kneel on two beans
for hours Lee
I was in the [__] room facing the
wall kneeling on two beans trust me she
made me kneel on two beans for a [__]
couple hours here and there
because she'd give you options either I
whip the [__] out of you either you
could write
or you could kneel on beans all day
naked
and you'd have to nail on beans naked
facing the [__] wall
and the sisters would walk by and giggle
at them and [__] he would cry stop it
Gina mommy Gina's making fun of me and
she commands that would happen one time
to be like I'm not going back to Aunt
Karen's house ever again like that
sounds like that never happened and like
I probably got Spanish maybe under 10
times they wouldn't spank me I remember
doing the [__] lines the punishment
lines and I also I'm annealing on the
beans and I also remember doing yard
work for four [__] days straight that
was torturous with no gloves with you
know like she would make you feel like
I'm in trouble so much at this you know
we would throw rocks I would be a New
York City kid that would go to Miami and
I would do New York City stuff in a
different [__] thing that they never
saw before and they would do things I
had never seen before
do you follow him saying to you so we
would ride bicycles and they'd say don't
do this and all of a sudden you know
like I don't know they would so we were
like let's say I was eight and our feet
though was six
they would say don't do don't pop
wheelies on the bikes okay because I
would send the bike down oh I would just
I would save my money all year and buy a
bike and when I went to see us down
there by the bicycle so when I would go
down there in the Summers I had my own
bicycle
okay so I could ride around with them in
those days you could ride a bicycle
without a helmet and knee pads and you'd
have to be [__] dressed to armor to
ride a bicycle it was Suburbia it was
real Suburban there really wasn't any
traffic we could ride around this block
2 000 times before we saw a car in those
days wow okay so we all had bicycles
down there so let's say they'd say there
was don't pop wheelies
and also no fito would [__] fall off
the bike and they'd say how did you pop
a wheelie no how'd you hurt yourself I
popped the wheel you're gonna tell you
not to pop a wheelie or get in there now
I'm taking the bicycle I'm gonna run it
over with the car but then it really run
it over with the car they would just
make them go inside he cried they're
gonna run my car over they're gonna put
it in the dumpster but let me tell you
something man I didn't get that type of
exclusive discipline
and you know what
I remember going down there when I was
about now Jackie and I are on the same
age
and I'm maybe two years older than her
feet though and maybe four years or five
years older than Gina
and when I went back down in age opito
was doing drugs but the other two girls
not at all
and then my uncle went to jail so they
had to sell the house and the property
and move to Atlanta
and while they won that land that's when
my mom died and I would keep in touch
with him and then I lost contact with
them and re-contacted with them in 84.
and the one girl was already getting
married the other one was already in
college do you think of the uncle hadn't
gone to prison he would have moved in
with them when your mom passed away
without a shadow
of a doubt
that was already pre-planned
while my mother was alive there was
conversations about me moving down there
because there was a school down there
called Loyola
private military school or some [__]
and they had threatened me with that
school and Rodolfo always wanted me
closer to him anyway because he always
felt guilty about my dad dying
but when I was a kid they were [__]
strict with their kids and let me tell
you something we used to go to
restaurants and [__] constantly
because they had though so the old man
would take us to seafood restaurants and
[__] and those kids were well behaved
and I was always well behaved because my
mom took me to restaurants and she would
[__] smack the [__] out of me if I
embarrassed her
but it's so amazing how I look back at
the discipline they had
and I look at how they turned out and it
doesn't surprise me
and so if they get beat the [__] up no
they didn't
they got punished the old-fashioned way
they got punished by writing up paid
listen
when you got that punishment you know
the eight o'clock hour where you watch
cartoons right you would get up eat
breakfast at eight o'clock you had to be
in the living room on the table we had
the card table
the card table was always set up year
round
in the corner next to the piano
that was always there for anybody who
[__] up
and you just sat there from eight to six
o'clock at night
and just wrote I will not disrespect Lee
again
and the eyes had to be under the eyes
the wills had to be under the wheels
that will not disrespect every Louise
how to be in the leads and you wrote
Pages Lee so you wrote from eight to
five and then you took an hour break and
then from seven to [__] nap time you
wrote again
but she always gave you a break on the
third day
you know what three days of doing that
is no you have no idea when she got
super pissed she'd make you write it in
English and in Spanish
and then my mom picked that up from that
that's when my mom picked that up when I
got older her and one would make me
[__] write lines constantly [__]
all day
it's uh
raising children is [__] tough man
and you have to make some wild decisions
like how would it make you feel with
like with your not with your friend or
even when as a kid
since you Guru up with discipline if you
went over and saw one of your friends
like back talking their parents wouldn't
make you like like it like freak you out
a little bit and he used to he's still
like what the hell is happening I could
make a joke about this but I don't
really remember who the family was I'd
like if I had to narrow it down
the first white kid I ever see
disrespect this family was a kid by the
name of Michael Olson from down in Union
Turnpike
[Music]
they were Irish
and I've talked about this guy before
because he's on Facebook now and he's
very unique now he's got teeth but when
we were kids he had been smoking from
such a young age
from my 10 or 11. he had been smoking
like he had eight or nine brothers they
were all Irish they all had freckles
they all had red hair
and his teeth were so cavities
and so green and so unbrushed that he
got cavities and he would put his
cigarettes
in the carry and smoked a cigarette
but one time you know
listen man you don't know what kids
houses are going to be like when you get
invited over there one time he called me
up and he's like oh I don't know if he
called me up we got together and he goes
you want to walk me to my house
and I went over to his house Michael
Olson lived off a Union Turnpike next to
a body mechanic shop where people told
cars and [__] like that his family lived
there didn't have much money
they just have nine or ten kids
and I remember going in there and the
mother talking to him and him saying
[__] to the mother
and my heart's not yeah it just stops oh
my God
it's like are you gonna die now like
that's just that you're gonna be dead my
friend's gonna be dead and they're just
not
I'm almost positive it was the elephants
he's on Facebook he's got a hat on and
[__] hysterical
like a [__] like a journey with some
[__]
you have the one comment
that just like could kill someone but
it's like it it's just for them like the
guy he has a hat on
like he probably loves that hat if he
lives he's like what's wrong with the
hat
you talking about I wanted him why does
he enjoy like that but this guy it's the
it's the normal baseball hat it's like
under the end of Jones had
why would you put an Indiana [__]
Jones title unless you explore you must
love it it's his Facebook profile I love
a lot of things I love to please what
happened
in The Outlaw Josie Wells not that scene
there somebody shot him but before that
with the hat I love that hat I can't
wear that first one to my head don't fit
in those [__] things I got a weird
shaped head man it doesn't fit anyhow so
from there on that's it but it's uh as a
parent you're always trying to figure
out how to discipline
and you learn how to discipline how you
got disciplined you know
I never got cracked on a whip
I got cracked with hands
a couple objects couple elbows you know
[__] like that I didn't even get that I
I still remember the first time I saw a
kid get like even just smacked in the
back of the head like I had never seen
it before
and this kid
I remember like it was like it was
yesterday it was my friend's house and
he had two older brothers and I don't
even remember what the older brother did
I think he took like a thing of pudding
from from the other brother
and the father just looked and gave him
a quick in the back of the head and I
must have like looked like a deer in
headlights because I had never like the
war
the only thing I remember about like the
few spankings or things I got is like it
felt like the Earth like the world
slowed down
like was it in slow-mo like that bong
hit
and like it was because it happened so
so like infrequently and it wasn't it
was just so weird but so the
when you were saying about like throw
the kid into the shower like that's
where you're gonna get some Kickback
these days
well here's the deal you're not hitting
the child you're putting a child in
shock
okay you're taking the kid out of his
comfort zone completely right he's never
been dragged on the floor and he's never
been throwing a [__] cold shower
before
that's going to blow his circuitry right
there especially when your mom does it
or your dad who loves you know who loves
you and now he explained himself to you
before it happened that's the key you
have to explain yourself which nobody
ever listens to it's this kid is not
going to listen to this is why this has
to happen
this is why this has to happen a lot of
people at home listen to me going what
the [__] are you talking about you know
it's tough to raise a child would I
[__] throw my daughter in the shower
if she would listen to me again abso
[__] lutely absolutely a cold [__]
shower and go what the [__] is your
problem
this is the deal here
this is the [__] deal in this house
this is how you have to behave yourself
this is how you have to act you know
it's uh and it must be weird just just
from the like the fact like you
like being over there tonight I could
never imagine
being annoyed with Mercy in two seconds
oh yeah she's gonna get annoying at some
age and she's gonna talk back to her
mother and she's gonna come to me for
[__] you know whatever leverage and I
gotta be honest with her and explain to
her that her mom is the [__] boss you
have to if not you lose the [__]
battle you know
so that I I know the position I'm going
to be
it's not like I don't know already I
don't see it played out I see the hand
in front of me I'm pretty Stern with it
you know I am pretty Stern when I grab
her and I talk to her
and then I hug her and I explained and
sometimes she cries
and sometimes she gets it she just gets
up and runs away and then comes back 10
minutes later we're right back where we
started from but I told her not to hit
my nose
and you know what three of those days
she kissed my nose
and she didn't jump on top of me she's
not a bad kid you know but when she gets
10 there's going to be problems when
there's six there's problems you know
there's always something but you have to
be there
that's the most important thing
yeah and and teach them well
you know something happened last week
spoke speaking of my teacher man I've
been dying to talk to you about this
this is why I'm
I'm happy to guess moved and it was us
because
I've always had a problem
especially when I was a kid I always had
a problem with
people
when we went out and did drugs
that was scared
okay so Friday night we're here we're
[__] around I'm still I get the
stitches out you know we've had this
liquid acid for God knows how long me
and Leland let's just do a little
droplets now I've been practicing with
the CBD oil because the thing's
expensive so you can't just [__] take
it like a Savage so it says seven drops
and you start counting the drops you
know so if he tells me it takes seven
I'm 300 pounds I think ten for the CBD
enough for the sake of deal no no so
remember we bumped into the guy at the
Chinese restaurant yeah and uh
one thing leads to another
and mainly have discussing this [__] and
I take the one dropper out and again I
tap this thing down to the least minimal
and I give it one to myself
and then I give one to lead now the one
I gave to leave was so small but Lee
moved and hit his lip
so that kind of is like a hat not even
I did uh I know what I looked at I in
fact if you ask Lee I did it a couple
times to see what a full drop was
and then I did it again and I just play
with it a little bit you didn't tell me
that's what you're doing but yeah yeah I
try to get the least amount in there for
us just to try it out Lee's never done
it before I haven't done it in years we
did the blotter that one time but I just
I don't believe in excess the first time
and we saw the gentleman they told us
not to [__] around so this time I go Lee
ready for another one Lee does a little
one again again I dabble with it Boop I
got a little one in there
I don't know if we did one right away or
we waited a little while I broke your
balls and then we did one okay boom
we do the three little dabbles somewhere
along the line I felt uh a little nausea
and I felt like my body
shivering and stuff but at one point in
the podcast I blew a smoke out I blew
smoke out out of a bong and I saw how
Lee looked at the smoke for a minute and
I'm like oh [__] we're gonna have a
problem here so I thought the acid was
gonna kick in for me really good the
podcast and the the guests left Liam I
stayed here for another 35-40 minutes
talking and I tell you what the acid
rattled my cage a little bit
but it wasn't like the 80s where I had
to go home and drink orange juice and
hide and put earphones on and you have
the sudden nurse to take a shower and
scrub your toes and all this [__]
Christmas to clarify we did the first
one before and we're gonna do the second
one till after okay so I I knew because
we did three of them right only I only
did two okay I thought we did three half
drops like real small drops maybe you
did for me but I thought I only did two
okay so that was it
Lee and I have a conversation I walk
home I'm gonna walk home I feel weird
you know when you take acid and once
it's mixed with your heart and you start
moving
now it's a different story you might
kick up the speed from you moving the
adrenaline kicks up the acid okay and
all of a sudden you're tripping and also
I'm like oh boy I better start breathing
out of my nose thank God they took the
stitches up and I'm breathing under my
nose breathing out of my nose and
finally guess what guys
nothing happened
I go upstairs I do my usual I wash my
hands I take a piss I wash my hands I
say hello to Demi he's in living room I
put the TV on I get some water I get the
pipe I get the lighter I go outside and
when I finish [__] smoking no pipe
right there I'm like I'm [__]
starving
and I go on the thing but there's more
to this story I'm sitting here afterward
with at the 40 minute Mark and I'm I
just have to go home I'm tired I gotta
babysit Mercy at nine
unless I'm legal is boy are you hot
first off I see him get up by himself
and he turns off the red and blue lights
in the studio
so I'm watching all this and I'm like
this gets [__] up but I'm not [__]
up
so I took the same amount as Lee I think
Lee took a little less than me because
one drop fell on his thing and I go let
me put it back in your on your tongue so
whatever I'm not accusing you of
anything Lee I'm just saying that at
that point I felt guilty because I'm
like when is this gonna kick in all
right Lee has done two things so far
that showed me that he could be seeing
something when he looked in the smoke
and when he asked me if it was hot in
here that's never a good sign when
somebody asked you if it's hot here so I
opened the door and then he says to me
boy it's so hot man I gotta take my
shoes off not only does it take his
[__] shoes off but he thinks his
socks love like it's the 60s in here and
he's like boy I feel better once your
feet are hot that means it's tripping
but again I'm sitting here guys to my
[__] God is my weightless I'm not
[__] feeling nothing I'm feeling the
reefer the Wheatley Stars no we had no
[__] stars that's why we took the
acid we smoked a lot of Bongos we smoked
a lot of [__] bombing speaking of
which it's time for nothing about it oh
Jesus it's your birthday bunking so
ah
I I didn't think my moment I go he can't
be this [__] high maybe he's playing
with me but then he says something else
to me goes dog it's still [__] hot me
and I go well then I don't know what to
tell you and he's moving the table
and I'm going why are you moving the
table because I'm thinking I'm laying
down over here then you're laying on the
couch for a minute yeah he laid down the
couch I'm like oh no but again I'm not
tripping so I'm tired I go home again I
told you [__] I go home and put
the TV on I drink some water
I call him back to check up on him
and now he tells me he's got his shirt
off
which to me is hysterical right he's got
his shirt off he's got his shoes off his
socks off he's in the office here and
God knows what he's thinking about were
you tripping at that point okay so
here's the thing what do you mean
tripping were you seeing things were you
hearing voices no I've never
the most I've ever tripped was
on one of those times with the blotter
and um like my keyboard like he's
started floating away but I didn't trip
like that this time
well you said at the beginning of people
with fear at that point well for me was
fear
because
it's uh it's like I'm not like what I
kept thinking was like I'm not supposed
to be doing this like I'm a kid who grew
up in Suburbia didn't I tell you you
were thinking that you told you you kept
telling me that I wasn't thinking that
at the point but then again I'm thinking
[__] I went to Emerson not even I got
good friends I had to agree why am I
[__] doing acid with this fat [__]
loser not even that just acid and then I
was actually a little annoyed with you
that you left I was like right I
remember because nothing was happening
for me I'm like and I can't risk taking
another one and being up all night and
then having Mercy at eight o'clock in
the [__] morning yelling in my face I
mean I could take care of anybody but I
couldn't risk taking another one I
didn't want to give you another one no
and but there was nothing for you to do
here like that was a thing there was
nothing you were gonna do and I realized
all this later
and I don't know with you this ad said
get you energetic is it looking upper oh
it [__] picks everything up okay
because yeah I'm I always walk around
like a crazy person I'm picking things
up I'm putting it down it's really I
start organizing I've organized well he
talked to me when he spoke to me and he
told me that he had his shirt off
I got a little scared from I stayed up a
little while longer uh now I call back
and by this time he's telling me this
[__] story
about that he got an Uber the Mexican
gangbanger showed up with a [__]
crucifix on the dashboard listen to
Spanish music it was supposed to be a
2007 what do you show up with 97 a 1997.
easily and it was it was like he was he
was creeping up the road like going like
probably his foot on the brake he had
music going
and it was just it was the kind of
leather where it really wasn't connected
to the seat uh whatever it was anymore
it was just kind of loosely there
and I just got in
and I like I shouldn't have gotten in
but as soon as I was like this is not
cool man
and then I had already put my address in
because I didn't want I didn't want to
talk to anybody I was like okay I'll
just put my address in I'll go home
but then he's like and then he kept
asking me things but
pretty much man he didn't speak English
I mean
I I felt racist the moment man like
especially with acid it makes you feel
really like shitty about like bad things
in your life so I felt racist but I was
like
man you need to at least be able to
speak English like a little bit like and
like I just didn't feel comfortable with
him knowing where I lived like it was
just I didn't feel it just
I'm not a very StreetWise person I don't
think I didn't well that was the answer
then you're also making your Ultra
parents right a little bit paranoid but
I could just imagine when you were at
when you got into the car it was like a
scene from a [__] movie oh my God so
this happens he gets in the [__] car
and goes back to the train station I
haven't take two lefts and take me back
to the track then he gets attacked by a
[__] hooker with a fur jacket on or
something like that what happened there
oh there I saw he let me off of the
train and there was this like a wild
pack of like you know the Warriors it
was like the black version of The
Warriors but they were just running
around and they were trying to find a
straight and like half the group wanted
to go one way half the group wanted to
go the other way and then I kept I was
just walking up a dirt path and I was
gonna call another Uber but I was like
first of all I didn't want him to get
the call
and I also didn't I just didn't feel
safe so I was just walking in this like
dark path next to the train
and this like in my head was a hooker
she could not have been but in my head
she was wearing like a big fur coat had
like a big furry like
something in front of her like a like a
big one furry box or something it was
really weird did she say something to
you no she like I was you know I was I
was very nervous that she was gonna be
like you want a party or whatever
hookers say and I was like I don't want
to talk to anybody right now and you
just walked back to the office I just
walked back to the office now when you
got home what happened now what time is
it you did the acid here at seven
o'clock seven thirty right what time was
it when you got home
probably close to one o'clock I think
what were you feeling at that point
still nervous
and real real uh energetic I was I was
going around my house cleaning
but I would only clean like one thing
like I would clean like one dish and
then go clean something in the bedroom
I'll just keep bouncing around my
apartment
and no voices no music no no nothing
this is just speed catching up you up oh
yeah I listened to some podcasts I think
for a little bit I tried to watch TV but
TV's always weird the face is always
that's where I hallucinate
with with TV
it's weird a little faces kind of get
jumbled up and like it always seems
brighter that the contrast seems off
and when you're seeing this what are you
thinking about all this it just it just
went with TV reminds me that I'm [__]
up I'm like oh [__] I'm [__] up
because when I'm nervous I just try to
convince myself I'm not that [__] up
I'm like you'll be okay you're not that
[__] up you're okay you're okay it's
getting better it's getting better now
what time did you leave the house okay
well it was it got better around like
three between like three and four
because here's okay just to be
completely honest I tried to to rub one
out for like an hour and a half
like it just nothing completely nothing
your heart's beating yeah because those
are sweating it's a horror show I was
trying to go to bed
and when I couldn't go to bed I was like
[__] off I'll stay up and clean and I
started have I started to get less
nervous like I think it calmed me down
like it just got my brain off of it for
a while
and I started having like really cool
thoughts I don't know it was just like I
just started like and I even said it one
point I was like this is why you do it
because it's
I always ask you like at the end of the
podcast when at like when we're 17 bong
hits in and a thousand milligrams I'm
like why are you still doing this
and like that's why like in my head I'm
like mad at you throughout the night I'm
like this [__] give me asses
left me alone
and now I'm freaking out
and I'm not sleeping and then I was like
oh because you have these cool like when
you when you
when you actually
stop freaking out you can have some
really interesting conversations with
yourself
and that's why
I'm not really and I've said it before
music for me I think would have taken me
out of it I like silence especially with
that sort of stuff so I was just walking
around cleaning and I would just think
about certain things and
and I
for anyone watching live
I decided to shave my beard at like
seven in the morning
and I shaved my head again but
at like
six o'clock is when I decided to leave I
was trying I was trying to go to bed
again
and I couldn't sleep and I was like I
need to go get some things
so might as well just go to the stores
24 hours
and it was great it was great
I had so much fun like it was at a point
where I could totally handle it you're
up all night no not a wink of sleep and
you felt great felt really energized so
what it was it was a hit you with a low
dose
you know because you did feel weird and
you did stay up and you did have dead
dick right yeah it was just a low dose
and the hallucinogenic or you would just
next time we do it we just take one big
drop and run with it and stay here for a
while and see how it feels I uh I'm
sorry I left you I just uh no no and I
don't listen I've been left I
part of me when we spoke the next
morning
and you said to me you had a good time I
was going somewhere or I had mercy
but for the rest of the day I thought
about our conversation that hey you
weren't mad and B you looked at it from
a perspective from somewhere else you
started telling me that next time you
wish you had a notebook I hadn't said
nothing to you about it and then you
said to me now I know why you do this
it's been weird
the last time I did it
which was with you and Ari
and then before that God knows me I did
it before Oh I did it with Ari for Pink
Floyd
and that was garbage it was okay but it
was it wasn't it was three hour that I
appreciated yeah
the we did it in the office one night
you and I without Ari because we did it
twice yeah that night too I was high
till 2 2 30 and by 3 30 I was in bed I
appreciated that
you know first off I'm a bigger guy
number two my tolerance is off the
[__] Chains It's even off the chains
for the oxycontins they gave me at the
hospital I had to call talking Lane go
talking later this ain't doing nothing
to me nothing he goes chew them or that
nothing then one night I woke up twice
with my [__] wrist hurting I had 75
milligrams of that [__] in me so there's
a lot of [__] that don't do nothing to
me and so don't take it bad it just
doesn't it's been years I don't know so
I have no acid tolerance I'm gonna say
something now and I'm gonna get it out
of the way with a lot of people okay
I get busted my balls get busted all the
time because people send me what am I
gonna do DMT number one look at my
[__] face do I look like I need DMT
in number two I'm too old number three
let me tell you why I didn't believe in
DMT and none of the properties just to
break myself down so people don't think
I'm a [__] [__]
when a couple weeks ago I was watching
that black mass with Rusty Bulger and
there's one scene whatever his name is
Whitey Bulger and there's one scene
where the guy is selling Whitey Bulger
to the feds
and they say that he's a psychopath not
to mention that he did experimentation
with acid and the cop goes you have five
or six times and the other cop goes how
about 50 times
and they all looked at each other like
he was Charles [__] Manson if I tell
you something I'm gonna tell you guys a
reaping Discovery okay I didn't get into
acid till the summer of my sophomore
year
like June of 78 after I hit the member I
used to run with this guy Lefty and one
night he gave me a hit of micro Dot and
that [__] had me going for [__] 18
hours Lee first couple times you did
that [__] that rat poison that's in it
that [__] keeps you up for [__] days
but since you're in training from the
Stars thanks to me that I'm a good
nutrition THC whatever and I watch your
[__] coach
uh you know you didn't freak out number
one you weren't scared
which helped but let me tell you guys
what happened so that summer of 70
[__] eight I get into microdon acid
bladder acid it's it we didn't know what
we were getting until Saturday
everybody always had micro dot acid but
we were getting it we'd get other [__]
whatever the people were gonna make
whether it was micro dot or four-way
acid our town was flooded with it there
was like three different neighborhoods
that sold that [__] in North Bergen
you know I got hooked on it until one
day I started selling and I started
going to East Stroudsburg and I've told
this story a thousands of times and I
became a business guy with this [__] and
it's so weird that I started eating it
since I was never a drinker guys my
excuse for not drinking
like you can't [__] drink into acid
like I didn't like it at all because I
like the acid high so much with the
marijuana
but that oh no because I was gonna talk
about that I didn't I messed up you kept
asking me if I waited the house and I
didn't think about it I actually had
some stars and some capsules so I took
it around like three or two or three I
think and I think that might be what
calmed me down yeah that takes a little
hedge off absolutely which is smart
that's the way I've always given it to
you every time we've had the mushrooms
this is the chocolate with the [__]
Edibles remember the edible the the
mushroom chocolate edible we had it was
chocolate with Edibles in it wrapped
around a mushroom and it's always a
little better than you said to me next
time I'll do it without the [__]
edible I'll just do it with the mushroom
and then I brought the mushrooms into
the studio so
my point being that it was really weird
when my mom died and I would go home at
night I can't lie to you guys I did acid
Maybe
five nights a week for [__] eight or
nine months
and then there was like another year
where I did it maybe three nights a week
because I had eaten it so much I built
such a [__] tolerance by the age of
16. ate in that micro dot I would eat
three of them when you would eat one of
them oh my gosh that's that's great but
one thing I got to be honest with you
Lee that you honest with me about that
you know what man every time I got high
on that [__] I took something positive
of it
I always I took something positive from
it if there was something that was
bothering me deep down inside or
something that had me all jammed up I
dedicate that hit of acid to that
thought and I'd break I'd go home I
couldn't wait to be alone
because you can't go there with other
people in the room with other people in
the room it takes the acid somewhere
else you start talking about look at the
car look at the lights
look at the steam from the [__] car
you know look at that but if you're in
somebody's house you're watching a movie
you're freaking out other people's faces
it's when you get home and your
surrounding environments
that that acid goes to work
see when you do DMT you're high for
eight nine minutes then there's like a
[__] three or four hour
after whatever but the original warmth
and the original Patois is a 10 minute
tops type of thing with the acid it
comes and goes and you have more time to
spend with that warmth
I don't know it's so tough to others to
make people understand that when I first
heard what DMT was I got it I'm not
putting it down from that perspective
I'm just putting from a perspective that
there's not much you can get from it
I'll give you hit a acid where you trip
for 12 hours like when those guys go
down to Peru and they eat that [__] and
they see the devil and [__] it's an 8-12
hour thing
because then it really breaks you down
if you came to me tomorrow and said you
know what Joey I I love doing the
podcast with you I love eating [__]
cake and donuts that Becky brings
but we know it's bothering me I'm gonna
go to law school
I love Paula
I'm Jewish
the [__] am I doing the podcast business
let me become an attorney and I become a
podcast attorney
you come to me one day and go let me get
the rest of that ass and you probably
eat it by yourself
and rent the hotel room in North
Hollywood towns
take two joints with you order your
pizza and just sit there for eight hours
and just think it over
that's what I used to do at that age
guys
I didn't take no add pill or Adderalls
or no I didn't take none of that stuff I
took micro dot [__] acid
to make me focus on whatever I was going
through
so I wouldn't like you know for a year I
took asset at that age just trying to
figure out why God would take somebody's
mother
do you know how deep of a thought that
is
no but in it
but did it freak you out or did you were
you able to like just don't talk
yourself through it because it didn't
it's an hour of crying it's an hour of
laughing it's an hour of hope that you
give yourself in that eight hour trip
remember you take it at eight o'clock at
night you start tripping at 9 30. okay
you eat your friends till 12. you walk
home by the time you walk home it's a
quarter to one you go in your house
you're pissed you drink some water you
already smoked outside now when you sit
out in the dark you could actually feel
it creeping on you once you're by
yourself and there's no other energies
in the room to take that energy away
from you you'll feel that acid creep on
you Lee
and if you're dark all of a sudden once
that acid Taps into your breathing
once you start seeing the bottom of your
eyes you're hallucinating your eyes are
wide open right it's catching [__]
stimulation from everywhere
now once the bottom of your eye sees
your stomach breathing heavy
that's when that [__] party starts
Lee
and now you have to start breathing
easier you have to break out a joint
maybe uh yeah maybe the star and just
sit and relax and maybe get a piece of
paper and pencil and close your eyes and
lay down don't try to go to sleep
but don't try to do more
I get sitting down but I I do my best
thinking even even now and I'm like I'll
I'll walk and pace around my apartment
like a crazy person
so I I would try to sit down
that night and I look at me I never I
never have a problem laying down
I was I was up the whole night taking
showers cleaning
I don't know it's fun I liked it yeah me
too there was a period where I took acid
just for that towards the end I like
taking acid outside I can't tell you
how many nights I went out when I was 16
and 17 and took hits of micro Dot and
tripped our balls off walking the
streets
in alleys in the back ends of North
Bergen between oh my God I can't [__]
tell you how many nights just walking
uphill on acid your heart's bumping up a
storm you [__] stopping to get air
and your trip
and you all stand there for seven
minutes then you'll look at each other
and go did you see that yeah come on
let's go and you walk 10 more minutes
and then you'd cease and then somebody
would have to stop to breathe
it was just a I'm happy that you looked
at it from that experience I was happy
that you weren't mad at me but you know
you were for leaving you alone but in
the back of my mind I left you alone so
you could see what the [__] it really
was by the time I called you the next
morning I wasn't mad and then I was
happy that you weren't fearful if so
many people who have to go home and look
it up on the website now nothing pisses
me the [__] off
when I give somebody to somebody when I
give you a present like a THC present or
something
and people gotta give me some [__]
story I think I have to go home and look
it up online or something
I wouldn't give it to you to poison you
I give it to you because I love you I
give it to you because I want you to get
to see the [__] devil you will you
just want to poison them no I would
never give somebody I would never be in
business to poison somebody but that
[__] always [__] pisses me off
it always pisses me off when people call
me and say hey man I'm definitely doing
mushrooms with my friends how many do
you think I should eat you know I went
online what are you [__] talking
about
this friend how long have you been
friends with him since grammar school
there's no trust
508 re-established eight [__] three
stems first off if you freak out you're
with friends
I would tell Lee Lee listen this is the
first time I did mushrooms so let's just
do them tonight here
and don't tell nobody
and it's just me and you and I would do
them and I call you a week like and go
all right
you sure I won't feel creepy if I do
this and you'll go no and we'll go down
to a bar and do the [__] mushrooms or
the acid do you follow me I would milk
you through it slowly I would never the
first time you did acid the other night
would I take you and take you to the
comedy stuff right you would have a
nervous breakdown oh yeah on the sunset
you would have a [__] nervous
breakdown that would not have been fun
I'm gonna give some shout outs right
here my main man J Rama putting the
pieces together
always emailing me telling me let me
know he's doing better and better Rob
keys my man holding it down in Chicago
Bob lalingus
Jordan Hutchinson John Cutler
Chris O'Hara
hot stepper
my family down in [__] Austin
waiting for us Lee's coming down 10
pounds Slimmer he wants to come down 10
pounds wider he wants to leave 20 pounds
heavy yeah that's a good plan so [__] it
we're going down to Austin soon with
being [__] Denver or being
[__] Oklahoma at the Cherokee
Nations Casino
stop it World Tour that starts in
Oklahoma who else starts their [__]
tour in Oklahoma or anybody else who has
that type of [__] not even Trump opened
up his American tour in [__] Oklahoma
and I'm flying out by you [__]
kidding me or what
then we go to Denver then we go on the
Oddball Fest West Palm bam [__]
Tampa bam [__]
Atlanta bam [__] Indianapolis
bam and then back home then I'm off for
a few weeks then the next week it's me
and my [__] main Jewish Goomba taking
it live to Austin Texas Lisa and I can't
wait it's gonna be so much fun it's
gonna be so much fun all right
but did I have the question everyone
wants to know what is it were you
considered for Trump's VP
slap on
Mike Pence
again I don't know who the [__] he
picked I'm sorry about the bottle people
I gotta know the [__] he picked no do I
care Lee cyan so that's it this is your
[__] 28th birthday yeah it's been
great
we have Donuts
well I mean it's a
to be honest it's getting a little scary
it's getting real close to 30. which I
know a lot of people may think I'm still
a baby but
that's like real adult to me
I got good news feeling abandons for you
okay I mean you became an adult when you
were 16. okay you became a [__] adult
when you were 16 you're working at a
movie theater
you were driving a car you know that
your parents gave you but you got to pay
for I paid for it I know you did you
know some [__] call what type of car
was it 97 Chevy Cavalier stop it a
Cavalier Rally sport edition let me tell
you something I used to have this teach
at a camel and he used to have a a
[__] car that was a Cavalier so when
you called to place the bet that was his
code name the great Cavalier
[__] so you become a [__] adult
you know what happened to me when I was
28. I'm gonna tell you what happened to
me when I was 28. what happened
I got into comedy and I got divorced
laughs
that's crazy
that is crazy
and
everything I thought when my life was
going
changed
completely
Within
six months
I went from having a family
to having nothing
and no job
and the only thing at that point in my
life
was uh because if we considered my whole
28th year
I got into comedy in June
of 91 that's when I was 28. okay and I
got separated in October from 91.
so two of the biggest achievements you
know two of the most [__] up things in
my life that happened happened to me
when I was 28. you know it's not about
age man
I'm 53 I'm sitting next to a 28 year old
doing a [__] podcast it's not about
age at all and if you grab every time I
thought about [__] AIDS I would end
up snorting two [__] eight balls
because I thought too the clock was
running out yeah guess what the clock
rides out when you decide it runs out
you know that's the truth the clock runs
out who knows what's going to happen I
wish you all the luck in the world Paul
is moving in your uh you know
you know you
when you're 28 29 30 you have to be
scared if you're not scared
there's got to be something wrong with
you like no you know you you know unless
you have a ceiling over you
and you're getting a guaranteed [__]
check every week should you
know we live off every month we don't
know what's going to happen Lee every
month there's a zero here on the first
until the smoke leaves
we don't know nothing
right and I don't mind that that doesn't
we don't know nothing so it's kind of
weird how
let me tell you something 28 you had a
lot more going for you than I did so
let's just start that I mean
complete Two Worlds you had a degree you
have a family you have a girlfriend that
loves you
you have
um
a little money put away you have your
own apartment at 28 when she left oh my
God I was completely lost I didn't know
what to do
I was barely hanging on I went from
having a little money in the bank to
having nothing
to my world shattering but I kept it
together with comedy little by little
those are my little [__] Band-Aids
that's pretty much my nightmare
I don't know I have people like
like that was something that freaked me
out on the acid
there was this dude like this like young
dude
who is like just drunk and like really
sick outside of the CVS
I was like God that could have been me
like why is he
was he like
you're gonna Bond and write a birthday
Bonnet before the show was over sure why
not
it's a late night you know what I'm
saying it's your 28th birthday I wish
you nothing but luck some people blow
smoke up your ass and they bring you
some [__] I bring you the best reefer in
town
and a [__]
and a good [__] thought that's how we
celebrate the [__] birthday well
thank you man over here at the church of
what's happening now and what better way
the Indians want they cut the skin off
their thing and you merge fingers you
were Blood Brothers I faint in my world
we can't make that happen
but the only thing we can both do is a
bond here the [__] death here and
here you go we'll pack a light one for
you
not come over here with Uncle Joe you're
not going first I did already I did like
two of them over here like a [__]
orphan and you're sitting there on your
birthday
you have the bong of the week and
[__] Instagram nobody [__] man
what are you gonna do you're gonna sit
down
hurry up the [__] the clock is
ticking we gotta get out of here
where you going with the keyboard leave
the keyboard
I don't know you gotta control the
cameras yeah all right take your time
but hurry up come on
let's do this [__]
look at you the birthday boy what are
you doing tomorrow night for your
birthday
tomorrow night
um Paula's coming over she actually I
have no idea how that sounds but
what the [__] are you doing here she um
I'll tell you uh we're going to the food
trucks
and we're just gonna hang out all right
hurry up with the bug here you kill him
come on leave me alone
let's go let's do this okay happy
birthday what the [__] I was singing for
you but we already did an early grab the
book I don't know
shoot that [__]
go go go go go go go go go suck and suck
it suck it [__] sucker suck it [__] suck
and Pop That lid
oh my God
hahaha
why is it so funny
happy birthday [__] I wish
somebody gave me a bung like that when I
was 20. nobody gave me dick and [__]
[__] suckers
and that's it this uh Thursday night I'm
over here tomorrow night it's the no
expectations toward the first night I'm
even gonna bring a notebook up on stage
I've never done that before but I'm
gonna make sure I run the hour just to
see what the [__] sounds like you
people might take the ride you might not
take the [__] ride what are you gonna
do we all [__] uh do okay we look at
each other and we shake hands Leo be
there as the Captain Kirk of the
Enterprise running the DJ porn and [__]
it's like a [__]
happy birthday buddy thank you man you
didn't finish this bomb what's going on
what is this you can't be a man I'm a
good birthday boy and share my gifts now
I'm gonna blow it out over here because
it's not
but now I gotta finish this thing look
at that you left a bunch of weed in here
you're lucky I love you and this was
[__] a different time to have you
stabbed
oh [__]
wait I got at least cyan what the [__]
you think you're dealing with
[Music]
[__] [__] happy birthday dog
I'm happy uh and that's it that's all I
gotta [__] tell you we gotta get the
[__] out of here we gotta go do spots
and [__] to do
and people to see the acid was
interesting
because of your reaction because of uh
you said you wanted to do it again yeah
and this time you would have a [__]
notebook and I was blown the [__] away
because everybody's so [__] scared
today of doing anything people tell me
after [__] when I get back with it
though God why did you why'd you bring
that back aren't you scared no no people
are not gonna give you [__] poison I
know they're looking on people's eyes
and they give you [__] poison dog
okay I know the reaction I know how
people sometimes act creepy I'll [__]
throw this [__] away but if somebody
comes to me and they ask me how Lee is
doing or that this is going to put a uh
this is gonna make Lee lose his [__]
mind I'll come over here and do it do
you know how many [__] different
places I bought drugs in the last 30
years
huh just two or three do you know it's
just a fear that
I don't know if it's yours and I'm not
insulting you I don't know if it's your
Generation guy because my wife is the
same way my wife and I had a discussion
the other day in the living room about
four in the morning I got up and she
came outside and we were talking about I
would have [__] I said something can
you imagine do you remember that night
you drove me to the motel cartel get
Coke
and you didn't really know but you know
a phone number one I left you in the car
that was in there for 15 minutes
and she goes I remember sitting out
there thinking
you just leave this guy now go home pack
my bags and leave
but she goes I didn't know how I was
gonna play out I go look how it did play
out
you ended up with a beautiful child we
ended up married
we're happy you know
so at this point somewhere you have to
believe that there is some type of God
out there
because I'll never forget that night her
waiting outside and I've never done that
to anybody I'm like
I've never ever made somebody drive me
like that over there I've usually been
the one that's driven or were both that
[__] high
she was just I was walking out the door
to [__] walk there
she was pulling up she usually pulled in
the [__] back by the garage
and it was like [__] three in the
morning
and she goes where are you gonna go and
I gotta stop my Dante's she goes okay
I'll give you a ride
and I never forget how bad I felt
but life goes on see you never know
where your [__] relationship is gonna
go
that's it I don't even know why the [__]
I told you at least I had
just don't be scared somebody offers you
something if you love them to death and
you've known them for 15 [__] years
waiting to do something give you
something [__] bad
but you know these [__] humps out
here don't take nothing from nobody so
[__] them what is your problem thousand
milligrams that's how deep you went to
that Lisa yeah yes sir when deep
training look at me I'm in deep trance
at least I have my balls of bleed
tonight I'm going home to bed
I'm a gentleman no but it's um what I
would tell people is honestly they do it
twice
because like if you can do what I did
and like come because people are gonna
be scared man it's
it's they they keep hammering into us
how bad drugs are
and
that's all we ever hear is don't do
drugs don't do drugs
and it's acid and I it's it tastes weird
nobody [__] when you came to
California Lee you never thought that
you would be doing a [__] headasses
at your job apparently but let me
explain something to you Lee sometimes
if you think when I woke up one day I
aspired to take a hit acid or I inspired
to do heroin High spine to do blow no I
never responded you think when I was
[__] Five-Star Basketball Camp
playing with basketball players I'm
thinking that about going home and doing
blow it was the farthest thing from my
[__] mind
but at some point in my life there was a
weakness and the opportunity to [__]
presented itself where I came from it's
all you go yeah let me take that hit a
masculine and I'll take it next week by
myself no you're here right now take the
[__] thing right now somebody gave
you a quail he just said yes or no
that time I went to Gunther's house and
I did the line of heroin let me tell you
something when I walked in there that
was the farthest thing from my
imagination at least I had
was to do that line of heroin I swear to
[__] God
so why'd he do it
because really at that point in my life
who gave a [__]
Talent though
at that point I was so far [__] good
and I wanted a begunly
that's the truth that I just did it it
was a little line I knew it wasn't going
to kill me I knew I knew that from
hearing stories that I wasn't going to
do a line like you do a cocaine lie
this was a very tiny white line
and I even took some off at just a
double just to do a taste just to make
sure that I did the other little
centimeter of dust
and that was it I just wanted to [__]
not be scared of it I think I don't know
it's not like I went and got high the
next [__] day you follow me
you know what I'm uh
I tend to like this stuff I have an
addictive personality so I'm glad I'm
scared of that stuff
like I've only even seen cocaine like
once
and like it was just for like a second
like I'm worried like if I did that I'd
be doing it like no no no no no it's not
doesn't fit you
because you it just doesn't fit you I
would never want that [__] around you
you know uh I bust your balls and tell
you about it I don't know I would never
bring it on the right oh I know I would
never bring nothing around you number
one that I would never do I would never
bring meth in here I would never been
blowing here wouldn't bring nothing like
that in this studio
the worst thing I'll bring in here is
like a 2 000 milligram star which worst
case scenario we go to the hospital
like whatever that girls they give you
some tranquilizers and you spend the
night and then you sleep tonight then
Obamacare takes care of the rest you
know what I'm saying you put it on your
own with obamacab what do you want me to
pay a month [__] it sometimes you either
edible and you need a [__] night in
the hotel room you know I'm saying in
the hospital room right or wrong that's
the worst thing that's gonna happen to
you we don't drink in here really
I'd love to get a few bottles of booze
in here when I know they're just sitting
here
it gives me [__] agile and gives me
[__] desires that I don't need to
understand you follow me give me the
[__] scripts and let's get the [__]
out of here we say it's been a great
week [__]
that's it
this shit's cracking it's July what is
it 20th already yes Jesus Christ
that's it the sum is [__] half gone
so yesterday I go over to this place
guys pretty [__] impressive you go to
indochino.com all right
and you click on location all right
and let's say you're a man whatever
and you're looking for suits let me tell
you what happened so you click on
location and also you press in Texas and
let's say you live in an hour out of
Houston you press it's also it comes out
Galleria mall in Houston
and and then it has do you want to make
an appointment and you click that
and all of a sudden it says
uh what is the appointment
you make it with time and they set
appointment set then you get a [__]
email in your house and that's it you go
down there you park you walk in and you
know me dog I'm trying to look for a
[__] complaint I get there there's
parking 10 feet away I walk in I tell
the lady what my name is I'm sorry I'm
three minutes late she goes don't worry
about it everybody's been [__] up here
with this traffic I'm real [__] whatever
boom I sit down she asked me 14
questions 15 questions you know me I
don't like questions but I didn't get
pissed off either and then um and then
uh she asked me to look at the fabric
then she asked me to look at the
mannequins with the suits on and see
what I wanted what I wanted two buttons
whether I wanted the same color on the
back of the collar just little things
that you never [__] think of that now
you have a choice but in there or not
the design for inside the suit for the
lining just cool little [__] then for
another five minutes they put they take
three pictures of you
with jeans and sneakers I didn't know I
was in Beverly [__] Hills people with
white people real white people they take
a couple pictures of me and then they
[__] ask me a couple more questions
boom 25 minutes late I'm out of there I
got a suit in five [__] weeks you
understand me and you get to pick your
own [__] fap anyway let me explain
what happened uh that's how they do it
you know listen uh Indochina is
Reinventing men's fashion and it's to
measure suit is the best suit you will
ever own so shoot up get one of a kind
made to measure suits customize the
details you want pick your lining lapel
personal [__] monogram and more
there's 14 unique carrot measurements
going into making a suit that fits you
perfectly you can't go wrong with the
well-crafted 100 Merino wool suit also
check out that made the measure dress
shirts and men's accessories and guess
what there's a money back guarantee okay
once you put these [__] suits on like
I put one of the suits on you gotta feel
what this [__] feels like I don't
know what the price is I don't give a
[__] I know if you're a young guy and
you're in the mood for Subway it's 3.99
3 [__] 99 I don't give a [__] if
you're a young man or you're on the move
or what the [__] are you doing do me a
favor right and go to get any pre
premium suit for just 399 dollars that's
up to 50 percent off
endochina.com when entering [__]
church at the checkout plus shipping is
free there's no reason not to try your
first custom-made suit with a deal this
good okay all your life you're like I'm
buying three suits for 200 likely would
you know I do it too all the [__]
time and sometimes I go down and I pay
300. I know it's the same suit they give
me for three for 200. they're [__]
thieves done it doesn't [__] matter
you even see it on a label it don't
matter you see it when you go buy the
300 suit don't take it to the same area
and go oh no no this is a better area no
it's not this is a custom [__] made
suit when was the last time you had a
custom made suit for 399 listen go
around there go to the website look at
the instructions I told you it's going
to blow your mind because I guess this
is the [__] future again go to
indochina.com
dot com
what's the [__] promo code church
c-h-u-r-c-h and you get any premium suit
for 399 dollars check this [__] out if
you if you just go right down the mall
next time you're [__] in the mall and
they got an indochino spot go in there
look at the [__] action you're gonna
die all right number two one of the best
[__] products I love this [__] I love
because it works it's effective and it's
[__] you know everybody comes home
from work you're tired you don't want to
go to the grocery store what do you do
you go to blueypron.com okay and your
[__] life changes you sending me Joey
let me get that water over there you say
Joey what is your [__] life
changed I'll tell you why because you
got one foot in the grave when the
banana period you're stressed out as it
is with blueapron.com you get home and
there's a box at the door with all the
ingredients you'll need to make one of
the most nutritious tasty [__] meals
and or a lot of their [__] recipes
700 calories put that in your pipe and
smoker
for less than ten dollars per meal
Blue Apron will deliver seasonal recipes
along with pre-portioned ingredients to
make delicious home-cooked meals Blue
Apron knows when you cook with
Incredible ingredients you make
tremendous meals so they set the highest
quality standards for their community
and with supplies and family-run Farms
Fisheries ranches whether it's Japanese
ramen noodles or the wild caught Alaskan
salmon Blue Apron is bringing you the
best do you understand me listen recipes
are created each week by Blue Apron
culinary theme and are not repeated
within another year you customize your
recipes each week based on your
preferences if you don't want to Billy
Goats into your house they won't send
the Billy go three hours all right you
choose delivery options to fit your need
there's no weekly commitment so you can
only get the deliveries when you want
them each meal comes with a step-by-step
recipe card and proportion ingredients
can be bed in 40 minutes or left what
less while they're cooking you're
washing your monkey you come out of the
[__] washer boom your dinner's made
again let me tell you the menu this week
on Blue Apron serrano pepper and and
goat cheese burgers I would eliminate
the goat cheese you know me but those
serrano pepper [__] hamburgers are
Delicious lemon chicken with green beans
tremendous shrimp
uh with uh squid and spaghetti are you
kidding me again shrimp with egg squid
spaghetti who the [__] knows how to make
that now you'll know how to make that
you meet a girl out you look her in the
eye you go listen you want to come over
to my place I'm gonna make your shrimp
with squid and egg spaghetti that look
just look at you number two spicy pork
tacos with a nice Crema on them oh and
spiced salmon nice and salmon and sweet
and spicy that's what they got from Blue
Apron Bradley you gonna say something no
it sounds delicious check out this
week's menu and get the first three
meals free free free and you get free
free shipping by going to blueapron.com
Joey j-o-e-y that's blueapron.com Joey
you'll love how good it feels taste and
created incredible home-cooked meals
with blue apron so listen you're gonna
make a good choice go to blueapron.com
Joey at the end of the day Blue Apron if
you're single if you're a family it's
the best way to do it go to
blueapron.com right now I want to thank
indochino for giving us a spot I always
want to thank on it.com go over there
right now in fact I ordered some
hemp protein I ordered some mixed greens
I ordered some
shroom Tech Sport and I ordered
something else today I just put the
order in because I'm all out baby it's
time to re-up I love you [__]
thank you for being in my life tomorrow
night Flappers next week I don't know
where the [__] oh next week I'm in a
ball with D'Agostino on Tuesday night
anyway stay black leave don't forget
about me
[Music]
thank you
foreign